foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
now you might have heard me sing that
song
it was September 12
2022 right after Amy Poehler and Seth
Meyer said
and the winner is
Cheryl Lee Ralph what
I had just won the Emmy Award for best
supporting actress in a comedy for my
role as Mrs Barbara Howard on your
favorite TV show Abbott Elementary
[Music]
oh yes
and I was
shh
as the children would say shookith
into disbelief oh my goodness it was my
first time at the Emmys and I won
yes and I've got to tell you
in that moment
I was so stunned into disbelief
that I don't know how I got up on the
stage
there I was just listening to that Roar
of Applause
and my whole career flashed right there
in front of me
starting with 19 year old Cheryl Lee in
her first movie being directed by the
great
Sydney Poitier
oh yeah you can Clap That
followed by
10 years of no after no afternoon
before the next film role came about but
I filled in that time with TV and more
knows and more rejection until
I made it big on Broadway in what has
become the iconic musical of the 80s
because I say so
Dream Girls
um
and boy did I learn a lot of life
lessons there and I mean after so many
moments of doubt disbelief
there I was
on that Ma stage with this huge sign in
front of me flashing stop now stop now
stop now and I started to think my God
what if I had stopped after all of those
no's what if I had stopped after all of
those moments of feeling defeated what
if I had stopped
I wouldn't be standing there
for that golden moment
but right now
many of us
we are feeling
deeply challenged
trying to hold on
and believe in ourselves and I do not
mean in a toxic way I am talking about a
way that comes from confidence the kind
of confidence that can keep us moving
forward when we are feeling
like we are carrying the weight of the
pandemic
trying to figure out all of this
political division fighting all of the
mental physical social violence in our
homes in our communities
to climate change
social media
it's a lot
making it hard
to believe in the goodness in the world
and heart is still
to believe in the goodness
of ourselves
this is a rough time people and our
mental health is suffering
we all need a checkup from the neck up
and I don't mean yeah it's okay you feel
me thank you
and I don't mean just medicine
I actually mean
reframing
our thinking
of our ability
to believe
in ourselves
now I know
you see me on TV in magazines on movie
screens
and you might be thinking to yourself
what does she know about struggling to
believe in herself well let me tell you
something
I do not look like my journey
thank you
oh I've been through a few things
and the struggle is real
but I have learned something in my life
that there are three things that we all
must do in order to believe in ourselves
number one
first
we need to see ourselves I mean really
truly deeply see ourselves for who and
what we are in order to believe in
ourselves
I'm a child of the 60s and that was hard
oh
in the third grade
I tested out of public school into a
fancy private school
where the only black person I saw
every day
was the one who looked back at me
in the mirror
I was by myself
and I was all alone
and the things that were said to me
and I'm not talking about just the kids
but the adults too
and when I would come home from school
crying the ugly cry
my immigrant Jamaican mother would sit
me down in front of the mirror and ask
me
do you see an n-word
do you see a liar
do you see a big lip monkey no
so dry your eyes and when you go back to
school remember
you are rubber they are glue and every
ignorant thing they say about you
bounces off of you and sticks to them
and I believed her
and it didn't hurt
so much
because I believed
number two
we've got to think
about ourselves in order to believe in
ourselves growing up my dad had a sign
on his desk and it said
think
I did not know
how valuable and Powerful the simple Act
of thinking was until I came back to
Hollywood from my triumphant run on
Broadway and I had this meeting with a
big Studio Hollywood casting director oh
I was so excited I walked in and he
looked at me and he said
hmm
everybody knows you're a beautiful
talented black girl
but what do I do
with a beautiful talented black girl
do I put you in a movie
with Tom Cruise
does he kiss you uh
who goes to see that movie
I I could not believe that that man had
just said that to me to my face
and he hurt me
he hurt me so deeply I was actually
thinking about quitting
until
I started to think
and I thought about what he said he said
that everybody knew that I was a
beautiful talented black girl
and that I deserve to be cast in movies
with the likes of Tom Cruise and he
should kiss me
so what was meant to break me did not
break me it built me up I believed that
man I believed what he said and I walked
out of there giving myself permission to
take up space in Hollywood knowing that
I belonged there no matter what anybody
thought about me
thirdly
we got to act like we believe in
ourselves oh yeah because when we
believe in ourselves and act on it we
create possibilities that never would
have been possible had we not just
believed
okay
so I will tell you another story
I will never forget walking to one of
those crowded Hollywood rooms and I see
Harry Thomason producer Harry Thomason
who is married to Linda Bloodworth
Thomason writer creator of the series
Designing Women
I walk right up to Harry and I say
how can it be that after all of these
years Anthony has not had a relationship
with a black woman
after all the show takes place in
Atlanta
Georgia
he looked at me took a step back and
said
who are you
I said I'm Cheryl Lee Ralph
and he said
okay
have your people call my people and we
will see what we can do
guess what happened
I got cast as f as Etienne son Bouvier
la Las Vegas show girl turned Anthony's
wife for the final season of Designing
Women
yeah
Against All Odds once again I gave
myself permission to take up space
believing that I belonged I believed
that if Cheryl Lee did the work of
honing her craft building solid
relationships and stayed ready so she
didn't have to get ready anything was
possible
heck
winning an Emmy
a Grammy
an Oscar
attorney he got it baby
so
when you leave this room today
I challenge all of you to start a
meaningful practice
of looking in the mirror
and loving what you see
believe in what you see
if you can't love it
then respect it and if you can't respect
it then encourage it if you can't
encourage it Empower it and if you can't
Empower it please be kind to it
the greatest relationship
the greatest one
you will ever have
is with yourself
believe me have faith in yourself
believing that faith can make broken
wings fly and we deserve to soar
remember
maybe one of these days when you pass
the mirror and you catch a glimpse of
yourself
remember I told you this
that is what believing looks like and
don't you ever ever
give up on you
I am Cheryl Lee Ralph and I love you
just the way you are
believe in yourself
as I believe
in you
[Music]
thank you